Comic book fans are a fickle bunch.
They can’t wait to see their favorite characters
come to the big screen, but if things aren’t
just the way they should be, things could
get ugly quick.
While the genre has no shortage of excellent
offerings, there are more than a few that
can split opinions right down the middle.
Controversial adaptations abound in Screen
Rant’s 10 Comic Book Movies That Divide
Audiences
Man of Steel
Zack Snyder’s Superman reboot is the foundation
on which the DC Extended Universe is built,
but not everybody is thrilled about that.
The film proved to be extremely polarizing
upon release, with the dark tone to blame.
Some appreciated the updated modern spin on
the mythos that made Superman a more relatable
and human character than ever.
Others thought the feel of the movie clashed
with Kal-El’s traditional values, creating
something that didn’t fit.
Snyder has tried explaining his decisions,
but he hasn’t won everybody over yet.
Watchmen
Snyder adapted Alan Moore’s ambitious graphic
novel to the big screen, and the results were
decidedly mixed.
Many praised the film’s stunning visuals
and its loyalty to the source material, engrossing
viewers in the world of the Watchmen and bringing
the pages to life.
But then there are those who believe the movie
can’t hold a candle to the comic, which
some considered unfilmable to begin with.
It also didn’t help matters that Snyder
changed certain aspects of the story, including
the ending, and that didn’t sit well with
longtime fans.
Though Watchmen was well-received, it struggled
somewhat at the box office.
The Dark Knight Rises
After The Dark Knight redefined superhero
films forever, moviegoers everywhere could
not wait for the sequel.
While it got plenty of strong reviews, The
Dark Knight Rises wasn’t nearly as acclaimed.
Many pointed out several plot holes and gaps
in logic, which made the story somewhat messy
– a stark contrast from the tight execution
of the first films in the trilogy.
However, several fans were able to look past
the flaws and appreciate the finale as a rousing,
emotional end to one of the finest film series
in the 21st century.
There’s no denying that the movie is exciting.
Iron Man 3
Shane Black stepped in for Jon Favreau for
Iron Man 3, looking to bring the series back
to the limelight after the second film let
fans down.
Unfortunately, Black couldn’t recapture
the magic of the 2008 original.
It’s true that RDJ was in top form and the
film delivered plenty of comedy and action,
but the twist involving the Mandarin infuriated
longtime readers of the comic book, upset
at the handling of Iron Man’s nemesis.
It was also seen as a wasted opportunity to
create a legion of suits only for them all
to be destroyed at the end.
And taking out the shrapnel from Tony’s
chest?
That’s a big no-no.
The Amazing Spider-Man
Rebooting the franchise just five years after
Sam Raimi’s Spider-Man 3, the marketing
for The Amazing Spider-Man promised “the
untold story” about Peter Parker.
What they got was more or less a remake of
Raimi’s 2002 original, playing back several
of the same story beats to set up Peter Parker
as the iconic web slinger.
This didn’t sit well with many, but there
are those who prefer Andrew Garfield’s take
on the character, seeing him as a better Spider-Man
than Tobey Maguire.
Garfield’s performance was a strong point
of the films, but the mixed reaction to the
series as a whole has caused the studio to
go in a different direction.
The Wolverine
Following 2009’s disaster X-Men Origins,
2013’s The Wolverine was sure to be an improvement…
up to a certain point.
The first two acts were very well-received,
with fans praising the story and Hugh Jackman’s
performance as the titular mutant.
But how one enjoys the overall movie depends
on their perception of the third act.
Many took issue with what was seen as a generic
comic book movie fight as Wolverine went toe-to-toe
with a version of the Silver Samurai.
It was hardly the most compelling set piece
and threatened to derail the movie.
Hopefully Wolverine 3 can be a more consistent
effort – with or without the R rating.
The Incredible Hulk
Hulk solo movies are hard to do.
Ang Lee’s version failed in 2003, and the
2008 reboot didn’t do much better.
Rebooting the character to fit within the
Marvel Cinematic Universe, it was seen as
a marginal improvement at best.
Fans enjoyed star Ed Norton’s turn, and
the Hulk action was fun to watch on the big
screen.
Still, some criticized the film for being
just a basic superhero film that didn’t
dive too deep into substance, trying to distance
itself from the criticisms of the 2003 movie.
It’s no surprise that a Hulk standalone
sequel hasn’t been made yet, though characters
from the film are starting to pop up again
in the MCU.
Batman Returns
Tim Burton helped usher in superhero movies
for a new generation with 1989’s Batman,
but the sequel wasn’t as big a hit.
Though many gravitated towards the darker
tone and performances of the leads, there
were plenty who were not impressed.
Batman Returns upset a number of parents,
who felt that the violence and sexual references
throughout the film were unsuitable for youngsters.
As a result, McDonald’s shut down their
Happy Meal promotion and the film took in
less at the box office, setting the franchise
down a dark road it took years to recover
from.
This is why studios like to make things family
friendly.
Ant-Man
A solid entry in the Marvel canon, Ant-Man
was seen by many as a fun heist film propelled
by a standout performance from Paul Rudd.
The smaller scale was also greatly appreciated,
after many MCU movies put the entire planet
at risk.
However, the lingering question about Ant-Man
will always be what Edgar Wright would have
done with the material.
That’s not to take anything away from Peyton
Reed, it’s just that some moviegoers feel
that the product we got could have had a more
unique spin if the Corneto trilogy director
was at the helm.
We’ll never know for sure, but at least
Ant-Man wasn’t a disaster.
Fantastic Four: Rise of the Silver Surfer
We’ll admit.
There aren’t that many fans of this movie.
Still, the portrayal of the Silver Surfer
character was well received, and many were
hoping that one day the character could get
his own spinoff film to flesh him out further.
Those wishes were dashed when the film underperformed
at the box office and was panned by critics,
a result that killed the franchise instantly.
We’re still trying to figure out what they
were thinking with Galactus.
Fox still doesn’t know how to properly handle
this property, so it could be a while before
the Silver Surfer gets his shot at cinematic
redemption.
Those are our picks for the most divisive
comic book movies.
Are there any we missed?
Which ones are your favorites?
Sound off in the comments section below and
be sure to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one!